ave nous on va suivre cette affaire bien
entendu on va tout de suite passer à
l'histoire du jour se passe dans les
vuges vous allez voir c'est une histoire
incroyable un hôpital situé près
d'Épinal dans Lesve a reçu de nombreuses
plaintes suite à 12 décès suspects de
patients opérés pour de simples
fractures une association a été crée
pour lutter contre ces décès inexplicabl
on va justement recevoir sa présidente
angélique elle sera accompagnée
d'azidine le fils d'une des présumées
victimes de cet hôpital regardez on les
accueille juste après ces images
regardez en un an et demi c'est la 12è
plainte
une femme de 78 ans est décédée à
l'hôpital de Remirmont après des
complications lors d'une opération du
col du fémur mais ce décès reste
incompris par sa famille qui a porté
plainte ce matin la direction de
l'hôpital a suspendu toute opération
chirurgicale non urgente jusqu'à mardi
soir des plaintes ont été déposées pour
des décès suspects ou des complications
imprévues contre l'hôpital le parquet
dépinal confirme que des informations
judiciaires et des enquêtes
préliminaires sont toujours en cours
suite aux différentes plainte alors
merci angélique d'être avec nous cette
fondatrice et président de l'association
agissez pour elle qui offre pour
apporter une aide unee assistance et
permettre l'accès à l'information à
toutes personnees rencontrant des
difficultés avecun un établissement
hospitalier on va raconter vos deux
histoires azidine vous êtes le fils
d'une présumée victime vous angélique
quel âge avait votre maman qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé elle avait 67 ans quand elle
est décédée suite en fait à une
hospitalisation pour une fracture du
fémurill 2022 donc c'est quoi donc
elleelle tombé elle est accident
domestique tout bête elle est tombée et
donc elle a été transportée par les
pompiers à l'hôpital de Remirmont
d'accord euh ils lui ont ils l'ont opéré
assez rapidement dans dans la journée
l'opération s'est bien déroulée et puis
donc il était envisagé qu'elle rentre en
en centre de convalescence une semaine
après cette chute là alors
elle rentre à l'hôpital qu'est-ce qui se
passe ce qui se passe à l'hôpital quand
elle est opérée tout va bien la semaine
qui s'écoule après l'opération ça se
passe bien euh on va la la voir tous les
jours elle va comme quelqu'un voilà qui
se remet doucement d'une opération euh
elle devait donc rentrer en centre de
convalescence le vendredi matin une de
mes sœurs la voit le jeudi en fin de
journée elle l'aide à préparer son sac
pour pour le départ le lendemain
elle lui dit à demain enfin voilà rien
de spécial et puis le lendemain matin
vers 7h40
7h45 l'hôpital appelle mon papa pour lui
dire qu'ils avaient commencé une
réanimation et que il fallait qu'il
vienne parce que l'État s'aggravait on
rappelle une fracture du fémur oui
donc on vous dit donc après l'opération
vous a dit que tout s'était bien passé
oui que tout s'était bien passé
effectivement on a pu le constater que
elle allait bien elle récupérait
correctement et votre maman devait
sortir donc une semaine plus tard comme
oui le jour de son décès donc et
qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce qu'on vous dit
qu'on son état s'est brutalement dégradé
et ben on nous dit rien sans explication
en fait on nous dit rien le matin donc
mes sœurs et mon papa étaient sur place
à à 9h la chambre est complètement
asceptisée le corps de maman est là elle
est déjà décédée entre le moment où ils
ont l'appel et le moment où où mes sœurs
et mon papa arrivent et puis on demande
des explications et là on a un médecin
et un anesthésiste qui dit ne pas savoir
ce qui s'est passé alors justement
queles sont qu'est-ce qu'on vous dit
c'est quoi la la cause du décès on en a
pas on sait pas
ils disent quoi ils mettent quoi ils
mettent ils disent on sait pas on sait
pas ce qui s'est passé la seule chose ce
matinlà c'est que la version c'est on
nous a appelé elle nous a appelé à
6h15 se plignant de mal de dos et du
coup on lui a fait un
électrocardiogramme c'est exactement ce
qu'on nous a dit on on en savait pas
plus donc euh il paril vous avez monté
votre votre propre banquête contre
concernant la la température corporelle
de votre mère est-ce que vous pouvez
nous expliquer parce qu'il y avait
certaines incohérences dans ce oui parce
qu'en fait du coup une fois les deux 3
jours après le décès passé on se dit
très naïvement qu'on va les contacter
pour qu'ils nous reçoivent se mettre
autour d'une table et puis ce qu'on
voulait c'était parler avec les
personnes les infirmières le médecin qui
était là cette nuit-là les dernières
heures de sa vie et pour nous expliquer
ben qu'est-ce qui s'était passé tout
simplement en fait c'était très
naïvement qu'on pensait qu'on allait
être reçu
mais finalement pas du tout euh on nous
on nous dit que de toute façon on n'a
pas à nous recevoir puisqu'on a rien de
plus à nous dire euh textuellement on
nous dit que des décès ils en ont très
souvent et que s'ils en cherchaient la
cause ils en finiraient plus euh et tout
ça je recontextualise on est à moins
d'une semaine de son décès quoi alors
euh vous savez également donc mon c'est
quoi cette histoire de d'enquête de
température corporelle en fait c'est
quand du coup on met une dizaine de
jours à obtenir un dossier médical euh
on se rend compte alors qu'on est pas
médecin qu'on est pas du tout issu du
médical que finalement contrairement à
la version maman n'a pas du tout appelé
à 6h15 puisque cet électrocardiogramme
aurait été réalisé à
2h15 euh notre maman on la connaît on
sait qu'elle avait une résistance à la
douleur assez importante alors on se dit
quand à 2h15 du matin elle appelle parce
qu'elle a priori elle a mal quelque part
ça fait déjà un petit moment qu' qu'elle
est qu'elle est en train de gémir dans
son lit ensuite à partir de là on a de
nouveau une transmission d'E infirmière
à 4h15 qui écrit que la patiente l'a
rappelé parce que la patiente dit ne pas
vraiment ne pas se sentir bien que cette
fois la douleur elle est montée au
thorax mais elle dit effleurage Faé
remise dans son lit à voir et à partir
de 4h15 jusqu'au moment où 7h on a une
autre transmission celle de 6h15 elle
n'apparaît nulle part et à 7h on a une
transmission des aides soignantes qui
arrivent dans la chambre et qui la
trouve inanimée et à ce moment-là a
priori ils essayent de de la a réanimé
son succès et c'est pardon alors c'est
c'est c'est une histoire de fou si vous
nous rejoignez à 21h1 merci 21h1 euh une
personne donc qui rentre 12 personnes
qui rentrent pour des fractures et qui
meurent dans ce même hôpital on va voir
les différentes hèes avec Chile dans un
instant mais c'est vrai que c'est
incroyable vous avez dit le ventre de
votre mère était particulièrement gonflé
alors qu'elle n'avait pas de problème
oui elle avait un poids normal elle
avait pas de souci particulier et la
chose qui a énormément frappé m sœurs et
mon papa ce matin-là c'est que bon maman
est allongée elle avait un drap sur elle
et qu'elle avait un un ventre ils l'ont
comparé à une femme enceinte de jumeaux
de 6 ou 7 mois ah oui comment ça se fait
on a eu aucune explication on essayé de
demander même à d'autres médecins ce qui
qui aurait pu arriver aucune explication
pas du tout Gill on va faire le point
sur l'affaire après on aura un deuxième
témoignage avec azidin et qui a eu une
histoire aussi folle dans ce même
hôpital il y a eu 12 victimes 12
personnes qui rentrent fracture du col
du fémur pancréatite aigu 12 morts
h informations judiciaires ouvertes
c'est ça et le silence total des
autorités judiciaires de l'hôpital des
élus de l'autorité de santé à ma
connaissance de tout ça il y a une seule
personne auditionnée depuis des mois 18
mois 2 ans mais un truc de fou l'hôpital
ne répond pas ils ont fermé de jours le
personnel dénonce des conditions de
travail abominables mais ce qui ne
répond pas à vos doutes pour le moment
les familles de victimes sont laissés à
ma connaissance totalement dans
l'ignorance ils n'arrivent même pas à
récupérer les dossiers médicaux c'est
cette histoire alors euh azidine vous
est-ce que vous pourrez nous raconter
l'histoire de votre maman ben en fait ma
mère elle a été hospitalisée à la base
pour deux fractures colle du fitmur et
du fitmur d'accord le un jour et demi
après quand je vais à l'hôpital pour
voir comment ça s'est passé donc elle
s'était fait opéré le médecin me dit
elle c'est tout s très très bien passé
elle sort le ça c'était le jeudi hein
elle sort elle peut sortir lundi ou
mardi l'opération s'est bien passée je
me dit par contre elle avait pas de
fracture elle avait une fure comme elle
avait une prothèse au niveau du genou
d'accord donc bah nickel quoi c'est
moins grave même à la limite non ouais
voilà et puis bah le lendemain matin ma
mère qui m'appelle à 9h10 j'ai encore
l'appel he elle m'appelle à 9h10 pour me
dire sors-moi de là sauve-moi voilà je
lui dis écoute je peux pas te sortir tu
es à l'hôpital tu as une jambe presque
une jamb moi elle venait de se faire
opérer à MH 12h3i elle me rappelle
pareil sors-moi sauve-moi et les visites
à l'époque c'était à partir de 16h j'ai
pris l'initiative d'y aller vers 14h30
15h à peu près je trouv semiinconsciente
sur le lit en présence d'un kiné qui lui
faisait un massage pas massage cardiaque
un massage au niveau de de là quoi d'c
et je lu dit qu'est-ce que vous faites à
ma mère il m'a dit je fais un massage
respiratoire voilà je me regarder dans
l'état calé et elle elle m'a regardé
elle m'a dit sors-moi sauve-moi je sais
plus exactement le terme qu'elle a
employé de là après il y a une équipe de
réanimateurs qui sont venus donc la
fermière qui est venu pour essayer de la
voilà ils m'ont sorti de la chambre et
après ils l'ont mis en soin continu en
bas donc bah après il avait pratiquement
voilà ils m'ont dit écoutez le pronostic
vital est presque
engagé le lendemain elle elle décède non
pas le ou le lendemain elle
décède donc je demande à être reçu par
une commission à l'hôpital de Remirmont
par une médiation j'ai le document que
normalement je vous ai donné la
conclusion c'est mort il mon dit de VI
voir mort mystérieuse mort mystérieuse
exactement ou c'est ce qu'on a vu mort
mystérieuse donc on rentre pour une
fracture du col du
fémur c'est c'est vraiment c'est c'est
banal he c'est c'est c'est banal et
c'est bénin c'est ça arrive tous les
jours c'est vraiment un truc une
opération très très banale et très
bénine et on repart B on repart pas on
repart pas et touche et derrière mort
mystérieuse est-ce que votre maman parce
qu'on on est aussi dans l'enquête ce
soir on se dit qu'est-ce qui se passe
est-ce qu'elle
avait comme comme la maman de
d'Angélique le ventre gonflé oui ah oui
pareil ou on onavait fait la remque
on fait la remarque et et après l'avocat
quand j'ai pris rendez-vous avec
l'avocat elle m'a dit elle m'a posé la
question j'ai carrément posé l'avocate
comment vous le savez ah oui elle vous a
dit est-ce qu'elle avait le ventre
gonflé l'avocate votre maman et vous
avez dit oui elle vous a dit quoi euh
elle me dit c'est gr bah voilà après il
y a une enquête quoi alors toutes les
victimes ont les mêmes les mêmes
caractéristiques plus ou moins on
retrouve des analogies c'est ça donc des
fractures et derrière on vient il y a le
ventre gonflé et on nous dit que
l'opération s'est bien passée et
derrière quelques jours après là la
personne décède 12 victimes dans cet
hôpital c'est c'est c'est c'est
incroyable donc azidine vous vous avez
dit quoi à l'hôpital alors bah en fait
moi en 2020 j'avais des problèmes de
santé ouais j'ai fait deux anévrismes et
donc bah j'ai mis ma santé de côté un
peu quand même je me suis protégé et
après ben je voulais pas me battre
contre un hôpital voilà j'étais un peu
seul quoi mystérieuse quand vous vous
dit de quoi est mort ta maman euh de
quoi est mort ta maman c'est une mort
mystérieuse c'est incroyable alors
l'adjectif mystérieux il est quand même
pas très scientifique cause de décès
inconnu à la limite y a un peu de
science làdans mais mystérieux ça veut
vraiment rien dire non mais c'est
incroyable c'est cet hôpital alors g
quelles sont les différentes pistes
parce que là on parle aussi il y a même
des gens qui disent a peut-être c'est
comme voilà un tueur en série exaement
tu en série dans mais votre question et
l'inquiétude elle est parfaitement
légitime et la parce que pour les
téléspectateurs j'aimerais qu'on voit
les différentes pistes parce que on
parle même je vous le dis d'un tueur en
série dans un hôpital c'est c'est c'est
incro ça sera c'est incro c'est ça alors
quel sont les diff alors pour le moment
donc il faut savoir que l'hôpital a
diligente une enquête interne sur le
dernier décès l'hôpital parle de
déclaration d'événements indésirable
grave pourquoi je vous dis ça parce que
du côté des autorités de santé il y a
rien pas une piste le néant alors les
les les juges qui enquêtes qui ont
ouvert des informations judiciaires
reste très muique sur le dossier soit il
y a un problème me de fonctionnement
dans l'hôpital soit il y a une
incompétence au niveau du personnel mais
ce qui étonne à chaque fois c'est que ce
n'est pas le même personnel donc ça
voudrait dire que il y a des
incompétences répétées soit
effectivement et ça Cyril on peut le
dire c'est une piste mais qui pour le
moment n'est pas éayée judicirement mais
c'est une piste et les les le collectif
des victimes se demande s'il y a pas un
acte de malveillance quelque part il
faut il faut dire très clairement que
cette piste là vous y pensez parfois
parce que sinon il y a pas d'exlication
tu oui quelqu'un qui
aurait des
pratiques criminell éventuellement on
peut pas aller jusque là mais est-ce que
est-ce que est-ce que quelqu'un cherche
à mettre en danger la vie des gens c'est
une PIST selon vous qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé réellement dans cet hôpital parce
que je sais que vous vous êes je sais
pas c'est vrai que on peut penser à ça
mais on essaie de de revenir à la raison
en se disant non c'est
probablement un acte de malveillance la
même des symptômes un peu similair
symptômes similaires
à mortème c'est quand même assez bizarre
quand même en fait ce qui revient
souvent dans dans les dossiers c'est qu'
ils ont tout devant les yeux par exemple
pour le cas de ma maman on n'est pas
médecin mais une personne qui a eu une
fracture qui est resté allongée une
semaine qui a des antécédents
pulmonaires on sait qu'une opération sur
un S c'est sur un Noos c'est très
emboigène la personne elle d'abord elle
se plaint de mal de dos quelques heures
plus tard au thorax à aucun moment euh
soit une infirmière soit un médecin app
c'est que des femmes en plus des femmes
femmes exactement donc c'est incroyable
12 femmes dans le même hôpital qui
viennent pour des choses bénines et qui
repartent pas de l'hôpital et qui décède
là-bas est-ce que c'est et c'est la
question qui revient et que vous posez
certainement chez vous est-ce que c'est
la même personne qui les opère à chaque
fois ah non c'est pas c'est pas dans les
mêmes services c'est pas dans les mêmes
services donc en plus c'est dans des
services différents Gill c'est ou oui
avec des mandes de personnel qui sont
pas là à chaque fois tous les jours il y
a des problèmes de personnel donc ça
tourne beaucoup donc non il y a pas pas
une récurrence d'une personne qui serait
aujourd'hui suspectée et cetera il y a
pas ça l'enquête n'est pas encore là et
le problème c'est que l'enquête il y a
rien on a l'impression que les élus même
du coin se thèisent pour je ne sais
quelle raison mais personne ne vient si
je puis dire au chevet des familles de
victimes pour les soulager de la douleur
il y a rien il y a pas d'interlocuteur
alors une enquête pour recherche des
causes de la mort a été ouverte oui
après le décès mardi d'une femme de 78
ans c'est le dernier décès voà
exactement donc le dernier décès
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé il il faut
dire aussi que les les victimes sont
d'âge différents
il y a ça aussi bah il y a là là du coup
l'association a interpellé le ministre
de la Santé monsieur Aurélien Rousseau
en disant cette fois vous devez venir
l'hôpital a enfin réagi sous la pression
mais ça reste totalement inexpliqué
c'est-à-dire que il y a pas une cause
qui est qui qui paraît en lumière en ce
moment Cyril c'est ça qui est fou tous
décès dans un hôpital c'est lu jamais vu
pour pour vous tenir au courant le
directeur de l'hôpital a annoncé
suspendre toute activité chirurgicale
voilà ils ont arrêté là ils ont dit
c'est plus possible et cetera mais il a
fallu 11 victime et que la 12e si je
puis dire survienne pour qu'enfin
l'hôpital se dise on va essayer de
savoir ce l'avoc de l'hôpital a dit que
tout étaé mis en place pour expliquer ce
qui s'est passé qu'est-ce qu'il a dit
oui mais rien il il dit ça non mais bien
sûr il dit on va tout savoir on va faire
la lumière ne vous inquiétez pas mais si
je puis dire Cyril c'est de la poudre
aux yeux jeté auprès des des familles
qui sont endeuillés et qui n'ont pas
d'exlication c'est que TR qu c'est allé
mais 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 et on se réfugie
derrière une enquête interne qui pour le
moment ne dit rien aux familles et puis
le fait que ce soit pas les mêmes
équipes à chaque fois ne veut rien dire
parce qu'il peut y avoir un mec qui se
dans alors un autre avocat présent sur
le dossier expliquer ses intentions il
ne s'agit pas de fait isolés mais de
dysfonctionnement systémique aujourd'hui
nous souhaitons obtenir réparation et la
condamnation de l'hôpital mais surtout
éviter que d'autres drames surviennent
l'ebdomadaire le point qui a révélé le
dernier décès parle d'un manque de
praticien et de turnover des membres du
personnel médical mais on peut pas
expliquer 12 décès juste par un manque
de patpraticien mais mais le manque de
personnel est pas attends ça c'est vrai
conditions abominablees de travail tout
le monde se plaint et cetera il y a il y
a pas assez de monde il y a un turnover
il y a une incompétence mais ça explique
pas ça asdine et Angélique est-ce que
vous avez essayé de parler à des gens de
l'hôpital leur dire voilà dites-nous
dites-nous ce qui se passe dites-nous
même voilà oui nous avec mes sœurs quand
on a enfin réussi à avoir un rendez-vous
pour aller retirer le dossier médical on
est allé au service où maman a été
hospitalisée on a croisé le médecin qui
l'a opéré et le médecin lui a posé la
question notamment pour le ventre pour
la température elle à 7h qui est déjà
descendu à 33°gr euh il a complètement
botté en touche pour le ventre il nous a
dit non j'ai pas du tout remarqué son
ventre était gonflé alors que ça se
voyait comme voilà et pour la
température la seule chose qu'il a dit
c'est ben non et toute façon elle était
pas morte depuis 3h non plus alors que
ça à aucun moment nous on a émis cette
idéelà devant lui mais juste est-ce que
vous avez pas essayé de parler même à
des infirmières à des gens qui
pourraient vous dire voilà j'ai vu j'ai
vu quelque chose il se passe quelque
chose jourl par exemple où on va dans le
service on voit les les infirmiers dans
leur bureau qui baissent la tête le
médecin arrive alors qu'on s'est encore
pas annoncé on sent qu'il y a une
ambiance qui fait que c'est l'omerta
total que personne ne veut nous nous
parler que et personne ne veut nous
donner des des renseignements nous le
dossier médical on a par chance réussir
à réussi à l'obtenir parce qu'on était
au mois d'août et qu'on avait pas encore
médiatisé tout ça mais aujourd'hui c'est
mort les personne qui parle dans cet
hôpital c'est ça qui est fou parce qu'il
y a toujours une personne qui dit voilà
il s'est passé ça moi j'ai vu si j'ai vu
ça non m personne non rien il y a rien
qui transpire oui qu oui et est-ce qu'il
y a eu aucune autopsie n'a été réalisée
parce que les principes maintenant la
médecine égale font qu'on sa
pratiquement à 100 % les raisons d' d'un
décès aujourd'hui pour la personne qui
est décédée la semaine dernière il y a
une il y a une autopsie a priori donc on
n'a pas les résultats pour l'instant euh
pour nous notre maman par exemple quand
on a demandé 3 jours après son décès
est-ce que Ben vous pouvez nous
expliquer euh la personne nous a
froidement répondu vous aviez qu'à
l'autopsie notre maman la sa dernière
volonté c'était d'être incinéré quand la
personne nous a dit ça c'était trop tard
et à aucun moment de toute façon quand
on apprend son décès on se dit que dans
quelques mois on va être là devant vous
en train d'essayer de comprendre
pourquoi elle est décédée on se dit
encore une fois naïvement qu'on va les
appeler qui vont se réunir autour d'une
table et qui vont nous dire ben voilà
peut-être je sais pas elle a pas
souffert enfin alors dernière question
angélique est-ce qu'il y a eu marqué
mort mystérieuse pour vous aussi pour
non vous c'est pas mort mystérieux non
non nous c'est il y a rien en fait on a
on a demandé un certificat médical qui
nous a été délivré un petit peu de temps
après et qui marque arrêt
cardiespiratoire j'ai envie de dire à un
moment on meurt tous d'un arrêt
cardiorespiratoire incroyable g où en
est l'enquête là l'association ben
l'association parle de circonstances
troublantes et le mot est intéressant
parce que on le disait avec y le
l'hôpital parlait de mystère non la
circonstance troublante ça veut dire que
quelque chose se trame dans cet hôpital
soit il y a un produit qui est donné qui
est frelaté mais ça se répéterait soit
il y a une malveillance mais c'est a des
dates très très très distinct inro en
combien sur combien de temps 18 mois non
au total Mo alors non le premier décès
de la personne qui est qui est adhéré à
notre association c'est 2018 2018 c'est
en 5 ans il y a eu 12 décès 12 décès
c'est énorme hein quand même he ça fait
bien sûr mort mystérieuse c'est quand
même incroyable oui trois enquêtes
préliminaires huit informations et rien
le mur du silence face au deuil des
familles c'est inacceptable merci en
tout cas merci angélique merci azidine
merci d'avoir été avec tout de suite un
film sur
C8